have no editor that tells me what to cover,
how to cover it, whether I can spend three,
six or nine minutes on it.
And the way that we are able to do that is
that we're mostly funded by memberships from
people like you.
Grab a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom.
Yesterday we did a segment about some of the
early wacky questions that we saw at the Joe
Biden White House Press Secretary Jen Psaki
s press briefings.
These questions overwhelmingly coming from
Peter Doocy, a reporter at Fox News who apparently
now is part of the White House press corps.
And we played some of those stories yesterday.
It is not just Peter Doocy now, but there
are now multiple reporters who seem completely
determined to make Jen Psaki White House press
briefings as much of a joke as they can make
them.
Despite the dramatic improvement, the upgrade
that we've seen from Kayleigh McEnany to Jen
Psaki, who actually provides real information
of value and substance, doesn't denounce the
media as an institution when they ask tough
questions.
So I have more of these.
We're going to look at some Peter Doocy clips
from yesterday and other reporters.
Here's a hypothetical from Peter Doocy.
What if what if the Senate can't do impeachment
of Trump and something else at the same time?
Another question.
The president says that he hopes the Senate
leadership can continue, can do impeachment
trial while working on the people's business.
What if they can't?
Well, as president, you always have to be
hopeful, of course, that's a completely absurd
hypothetical that again, doesn't even involve
Biden, Peter Doocy and other right wing reporters
determined to say to Jen Psaki and to Joe
Biden and others, shouldn't you intervene
in the Senate impeachment trial and either
say to do this or to do that or to not do
this again?
Joe Biden should have no involvement whatsoever
in the Senate impeachment trial.
He shouldn't tell any senator on the Republican
or Democratic side to do something or not
to do something.
He should simply not be involved in any way.
And that is going to be hopefully the continued
response from Jen Psaki and from Joe Biden.
Peter Doocy, then with another question, shouldn't
the rioters in Portland also be seen as domestic
extremists?
If you are seeing the January 6th rioters
as domestic extremists or domestic terrorists?
Just one more, the riots in Portland and the
violence in Portland.
Recently, there was some discussion earlier
about the January 6th writers being reviewed
by the DNI as domestic violent extremists.
Are the rioters in Portland also being viewed
through the same lens, or is that something
different as the White House?
I think we and I talked about this yesterday
and conveyed that all the violence happening
around the country will be reviewed.
So what Jen Psaki does well is not react much
and just say, Yashar, review everything she
could say.
Well, hold on a second, Peter.
What we had on January 6th was X incited by
the sitting, then sitting president of the
United States.
What we've seen in Portland is something very
don't even get into it.
Just tell him we're going to look at everything
and review everything.
Yeah, sure.
Why not?
Because that he wants to get a reaction from
her and she does a good job of not giving
him one here.
He asks.
And again, this is but it's the same hypotheticals.
Is Joe Biden supportive of Florida hosting
the Olympics?
If Japan backs out due to coronavirus fears?
Is a report now that the chief financial officer
of Florida has sent a letter to the International
Olympic Committee that Florida would like
to host the Olympics in Japan next year is
uncomfortable because of the pandemic.
Is a Florida Olympics in 2021 something that
you can see the White House supporting?
Well, that's a lot of steps that need to take
place.
And I don't know the entire process of the
Olympics, but I would certainly think send
you to the U.S. Olympic Committee and the
International Olympic Committee first on what
their assessment of that offer is, and certainly,
of course, what their assessment is of Japan's
preparedness for the Olympics.
This is you know, he he might as well go to
my type of question.
Jen, does the Biden administration believe
that a taco is a type of pizza is an empanada,
a Latin American calzone?
From the perspective of the Biden administration?
These are meaningless questions.
And by the way, on the merits, it's ridiculous.
But I'll get to that in a second.
If it is true that Japan decides in the future
not to do the Olympics and if it is true that
Florida is interested and capable of doing
it, what would Joe Biden's pick.
Give me a break.
And by the way, the funniest thing about that
is Japan as a country has far better coronavirus
numbers than Florida.
And Florida is just one of 50 American states,
Japan as a country, if Japan is a country
says based on the data, we don't want to do
the Olympics due to covid, there's no way
in hell that it should go to Florida.
Florida's been a much bigger disaster.
OK, another reporter jumps in and asks, what
is Donald Trump?
What is the I'm sorry, what is Joe Biden's
position on Donald Trump endorsing Sarah Huckabee,
Sanders in the Republican Arkansas gubernatorial
primary of 2022?
Yeah, you might be wondering what what, why,
why, why would Joe Biden take a position on
that?
And indeed, he is not.
Take a look at this.
Yesterday, former President Trump endorsed
Sarah Huckabee, Sanders for governor of Arkansas
in 2022.
Where is President Biden stand on that particular
race?
And how high is this on his list of priorities?
Well, how high is the Arkansas Republican
gubernatorial primary on the president's list
of priorities?
Not high.
I can confirm for you, I'm not running for
governor of Connecticut in the future, so
I'm here to confirm that for you as well.
These are just completely farcical questions.
And we'll talk a little bit later in the show
about Sarah Huckabee Sanders gubernatorial
run.
Here is one more back to Peter Doocy asking
Joe Biden, what did you talk to Vladimir Putin
about?
And Biden handles this perfectly and says,
we talked about you, Peter.
This president wants to talk to you, about
you.
I do find it entertaining that Joe Biden clearly
finds Peter Doocy entertaining and he seems
to deliberately let him ask questions.
And what is absolutely fascinating to me is
that on the one hand, these reporters like
Peter Doocy, they seem determined to turn
the press briefings with Jen Psaki and with
Biden himself into opportunities to attack
people with questions.
Now, I think that that's fine.
Notice how different the reaction is from
Jen Psaki and from Joe Biden.
The Trump administration would have maybe
kicked him out, as they did at one point.
The CNN reporter, Jim Acosta, they would have
denounced the media as an institution.
They would have scolded the entire room because
they didn't like the question from one person.
I like that Jen Psaki and Joe Biden just answer
the questions with the seriousness that they
deserve on a case by case basis.
And sometimes these questions don't really
require a very serious answer,